now from politics and prose bookstore in
Washington DC Justin Martin discusses
his new biography of consumer advocate
and 2000 presidential candidate Ralph
Nader it's about an hour please help me
welcome Justin Martin was a pleasure to
be here at politics and prose to talk
about Ralph Nader and thank you everyone
for coming out tonight so look around
the audience I see some friendly faces
including my cousins who live here in
Washington DC and some old friends from
college and other times of my life so
welcome everybody and thanks for coming
out and thought what I do is I'd start
by providing kind of a thumbnail sketch
of Ralph Nader's early years then I'm
going to talk for a while about a
particular period in his history then
I'll read a brief excerpt that relates
to that period in time then I'll be
happy to entertain any and all questions
we can talk about 2000 election we can
talk about the two thousand two midterms
whatever people want to talk about i'll
be happy to entertain questions so
starting with the sort of brief
thumbnail sketch of his early years
Ralph Nader was born on februari 27th
1934 in Winsted Connecticut his parents
were Lebanese immigrants and his father
upon arriving the United States before
for one year before settling in Winsted
Connecticut he lived in Detroit and
while he was in Detroit he worked on the
assembly line of maxvill auto company
and Maxwell auto company was later
rechristened Chrysler and when Ralph
Lena was growing up at the dinner table
he often was rigged a lot of the
degradation of working on the assembly
line of Maxwell auto company and people
could make of it what they will as to
whether that had any kind of influence
in his later life as an auto safety
Crusader Ralph Kiner has two sisters
Claire and Laura Claire Nader is a
advocate kind of in a Ralph Nader type
of vein her area of interest is genetic
testing patenting of jeans those types
of issues and as you can imagine she's
against it Ralph Nader's other sister
laura is an anthropology professor at
Berkeley and Laura Laura's area of
expertise is victims rights Ralph Nader
also had a brother named shafiq on
shafiq was when I interview people they
often described him as being to the town
of Winsted Connecticut where they grew
up what Ralph Nader was to the rest of
the country he was a very vocal gadfly
he was always complaining at town
meetings about the sewer system he was
always trying to shoot down various
local ordinances and I'm shafiq died in
1986 Ralph Nader went to Princeton
University undergrad and he attended at
the same time as Donald Rumsfeld
Rumsfeld at that time was kind of a big
man on campus he was on the wrestling
team and during one of my interviews
with Ralph Nader he described Rumsfeld
as the smug wrestler while Ralph Nader
was at Princeton he owned his last car
last car he would ever dry which was an
old Studebaker one time he was driving
around on campus this kind of abstracted
looking man with flowing white hair kind
of wandered out into the line of his car
Ralph Nader had to slam on the brakes he
stopped right before this person looked
up through his front window and there
standing before him was Albert Einstein
and he thought to himself what if the
brakes had worked I would have run over
one of the great minds of the 20th
century and again you can make of it
what you will as to whether that had
some influence on his later decisions
become an auto safety Crusader he did
get rid of the Studebaker not too long
after that let's see after after
Princeton undergrad Ralph Nader wanted
the Harvard Law School never felt
comfortable there he never had always
has had a sort of ambivalent
relationship towards the school and in
the years since then he's often
described Harvard is a high-priced tool
factory it's now after gret now after
graduated Harvard Law he went back to
Connecticut back to Hartford they
practice what can only be described as
penny-ante law he was doing divorce
cases trust he was a little tiny firm
with one other person he was doing some
ambulance-chasing even though this is
very low level law at the same time he
was developing an interest sort of as a
sideline and a topic that that time was
very very esoteric which was the
engineering the role that engineering
could play an auto safety it's kind of
hard to believe but during this era the
prevailing belief was that all the
engineering innovations possible had
been made with respect to cars the only
thing that could be done the only
improvements that could be made or for
people to drive more carefully safer
driving ralph nader was of the belief
and it was a
in view that maybe their innovations
things that we've come to take for
granted like seat belts safety glass
collapsible steering columns that maybe
if you could package drivers within the
cars better even if they're a sloppy
driver they might be saved in an
accident now in 1964 Ralph Nader got the
opportunity to go down to Washington and
work with daniel patrick moynihan who's
one of the handful of people who also
subscribe to this kind of esoteric view
about the role that engineering could
play and safety and while Ralph Nader
was down in Washington working with
Moynihan he he sort of laid the
groundwork for unsafe at any speed which
came out in the autumn of 1965 and
looking back people probably might think
that unsafe at any speed was just an
instant sensation but in fact it was it
was a very serious book it was taken
very seriously it was reviewed in some
places like science magazine and San
Francisco Chronicle and people sort of
did a lot of discussion of how it was an
important book and it was destined to
sink without a ripple had it not been
for the fact that one of the parties
named in the book pointed to in the book
General Motors was very concerned about
ralph nader's pointed to them for their
what he asserted was faulty engineering
in the production of the Corvair and so
they assigned a couple of spies to tail
him around Washington DC also Nader had
some strange experiences when he went
into a Safeway at one point also at a
newsstand at one point where he was
accosted by women and Ralph Nader had
the belief or had a notion that maybe
these were sex slurs put upon him by
some somebody who was looking into his
background to maybe discredit him and so
he mentioned the fact that he thought he
was being tailed to a guy named James
Ridgeway who at the time was a reporter
for The New Republic Ridgeway did some
digging and was actually able to find
out that yes in fact General Motors
there was some detailing it was General
Motors he broke the story I just created
an immediate splash now this time NATO
was doing very sort of quiet not
particularly closely followed testimony
before Congress on the topic of auto
safety and when it was when the story
was broken that Ralph Nader had been
tailed by these spies the person who
oversaw the congressional committee
before which to Ralph Nader was
testifying demanded the president of GM
appear before the subcommittee to
apologize for her
and congressional witness and is set up
an incredible and dramatic David and
Goliath confrontation where this
diligent hard-working serious public
private citizen had been wronged by the
largest corporation in the world and the
president the company James Roche went
before Congress and on national
television apologized to Ralph Nader in
an instant he was someone who people had
heard of people were talking about and
of course even for that he would have
been as simply an historical footnote
had it not been for the fact that he
kind of grabbed that event grabbed that
bit of profile that he gained and just
ran with it and what I want to talk
about tonight after giving that sort of
thumbnail sketch of his early years I'm
as a period from about 1966 not long
after the publication of unsafe at any
speed which then did go high up on the
bestseller list from period about mid
nineteen sixty-six through the early
1970s during which the Ralph Nader was
just lose ascendant and as a biographer
for me one of the great pleasures and
also when the great challenges is trying
to sort of make sense of a bygone era of
a time that's its kind of lost in
history and it's it's in credits almost
impossible to overstate how important
what a huge figure Ralph Nader was
during this era and there's several
factors that come into play and wanted
to spend some time discussing them
before reading an excerpt that relates
to that particular period first of them
was during this era he is an incredible
grasp of how to work with the media and
he was just superb at cultivating
reporters like Morton mints a reporter
for The Washington Post Jack Morris
somebody at the New York Times he had a
superb ability to figure out what their
deadlines were what their needs were
what their territory was how to deliver
information to them in a timely fashion
he also he was a great tactician with
the media one of his greatest tactics
was the weekend interview he certainly
couldn't reach a CEO over the weekend a
reporter certainly couldn't reach a
member of Congress over the weekend but
Ralph Nader was available over weekends
as a consequence Sunday and Monday
papers slow news days were often
sprinkled with Ralph Nader stories he
was also a support absolutely superb
phrase maker Ralph Nader can
with phrases during that era such as
crime in the Suites to refer to
corporate crime versus crime in the
streets at one point he did a
investigation to the fat content on the
nutritional labels of hot dogs and
hamburgers and he came up with the
phrases fat furthers and sham burgers
and these phrases were picked up in
places like Newsweek and Time magazine
plenty of other people during this era
were muckraking just as nadir was but
because they didn't have the same
capacity for phrase making they were
overlooked another neater tactic great
Nader tactic was the prepackaged story
he put together a set of materials that
gave his perspective on a matter then
he'd write down the name and phone
numbers of people who were likely to
reiterate his perspective then he'd
write down a couple names and phone
numbers of people who are likely to
rebut his perspective and he'd go and
hand deliver it to a lazy reporter who
would then just make a few phone turn
off their brain make a few phone calls
read the materials prepackaged story
bear in mind also that during this
period of ascendancy for Ralph Nader was
it was pre Watergate and before
Watergate a lot of newspapers didn't
really provide the same level of
resources for Investigative Reporting it
just wasn't the kind of venture that it
became after Watergate meanwhile Ralph
Nader was off doing things like going
down to West Virginia looking into black
lung disease among the miners and so you
could have somebody at a major
metropolitan daily who the paper was
unwilling to spring them they go off the
West Virginia for a month that they just
reported on Ralph Nader and his doings
they could be kind of a muckraker by
proxy and it was a lot of that in this
era one other thing that really struck
me with respect to the media and the
course is doing my research I had to
look at literally almost every day's
worth of the New York Times and
Washington Post from during the 0 and
regularly Ralph Nader would be on the
front page two or three times a week in
these major metropolitan dailies and
often all that the story was was a
dutiful recounting of a press conference
that Ralph Nader had held it would just
say Ralph Nader held a press conference
today to discuss the fact that the wix
in a certain kind of candle have the
risk of throwing lead into the
environment or into the air and the end
of the story would have a little bit of
dutiful rebuttal where you know the
American candle-making Association says
Ralph Nader's all wet he's you know he's
up to his old tactics again
it was incredible I mean he called a
press conference front page of the
Washington Post front page of the New
York Times the fact that Ralph Nader was
in the media was so ever-present the
media guaranteed that Congress would pay
attention to him a part of this is just
good old-fashioned and light and
self-interest Senators knew that if
Ralph Nader testified before their
committee that the cameras would be
there the press would be there with her
notebooks and maybe if they said
something maybe it would get beamed back
to the constituents back home Nader was
also for the same reasons that he was
such a talented that he had such a grasp
of how to make phrases that were picked
up by the media he also was really good
in congressional testimony for many of
the same reasons great phrase maker he
was also he had sort of an air of
controlled outrage that he was able to
communicate and I remember when I was
doing my research I spoke with a person
who is a legislative aide to Teddy
Kennedy back in the late 1960s and he
told me that he had an incredible coup
where he managed to get Paul Newman to
come before Congress to testify and he
expected this would be great that this
would go off very well the Paul Newman
proved to really be very poor at
testimony he just he didn't have he was
a movie star but he did not have the
seriousness of the gravitas Nader had
that and that made him again an
excellent it made him very sought-after
during that era to testify before
Congress it's something that these days
he actually he barely ever appears
before Congress at all in this era it
was not unusual for him to appear before
various subcommittees once or twice a
week he's also as he was with the media
he was a great tactician with Congress
and one of his great techniques was to
call up the senator and say or meet a
senator and say mr. senator would it be
possible for me to make the introduction
of one of your staff people and the
senator was happy to oblige and VIN is
now senators are busy making public
appearances trying to get reelected but
it's often the staff people that have
their fingers in the nitty gritty
details they're the ones who might set
the legislative agenda they're the ones
who are considering a bill how and what
form it may be considered in what form
it might be passed so in effect by media
senator and saying and sort of
networking down saying can I get to know
your staff person he then in turn got to
know a person who then could influence
the senator in a very substantial and
significant way
one more great nader tactic was the
patented late night phone call and ralph
nader had no compunction about calling a
senator at two or three in the morning
now CEOs wouldn't do that certainly
would not get a call in the middle of
the night from another senator the Ralph
Nader did and it did a lot towards
communicating that here is this guy who
was a public servant members of Congress
of course hoped to be or perceive
themselves as public servants well here
was a guy who'd call you in the middle
of the night things were so urgent he
couldn't wait till the next morning and
it's worked very very effective
technique Walter Mondale who has just
become tried to become a senator once
again last week when he ran from
Minnesota was someone who worked very
closely with Ralph Nader back at in the
60s particularly on the wholesale meat
act in 1967 and Mondale used to get
calls in the middle of the night and he
got into the habit of just picking up
the phone saying hi Ralph now the fact
that he was a media darling and the fact
that he had this incredible profile for
Congress guaranteed that Ralph Nader
would get a ton of mail and the mail was
an amazing resource for him because it
gave him a way of really having his
finger on the pulse of the populace and
what ailed the populace in terms of
consumer problems he would get mail that
said you know a particular model of car
was it was a lemon he get mail that said
from people who said that they were
experiencing a certain type of insurance
fraud and so he'd get a real read on
what kinds of problems were out there he
also got a lot of letters often
anonymous letters in which people reveal
that they were whistled in which people
act as whistleblowers which they wrote
to him and said you know I work in such
and so plan I just wanted to alert you
about a practice at our plant that
threatens the workers of threatens the
environment or what have you now during
this year Oh Ralph Nader headed up an
organization called the Center for the
Study of responsive law which still
exists today and he still heads it up
people that were somewhat intrepid would
figure out that this was his
organization and they learned the
address and they'd send him a piece of
mail at the Center for the Study of
responsive law of course a lot of other
people couldn't figure that out
necessarily or didn't bother to but they
often they might read an article in the
in the Time magazine or Newsweek a
profile that mentioned that his family
still lived in Winsted Connecticut so
his family in Winstead got a huge volume
of mail
that said please forward this on the
Ralph Nader and his mother would
dutifully go through the letters and
mark them up read this Ralph ignore this
one and send them on to him in
Washington other people simply just took
a stab in the dark and wrote Ralph Nader
Washington DC or Ralph Nader senator
Washington DC which wasn't even true yet
a huge number of these letters still
made it to Ralph Nader who then this
during this era he he occupied am sort
of crumbling victorian-era mansion near
near Dupont Circle and all around the
mansion was sort of a haphazard effort
to catalog and categorize these
different letters that came in so there
are piles for bum toaster ovens and
piles for you know lemon Volkswagens and
so forth now during the 02 there were
just a huge number of people who wanted
to work for Ralph Nader and he ended up
hiring these teams of mostly young
people who would go off and do often
concurrent investigations of all kinds
of different instances of fraud and
malfeasance he'd have people looking
into the doings of various corporations
such as DuPont and what was then called
first national city bank he had people
looking into what were then very corrupt
government agencies such as the FTC had
them looking into topics such as land
use in California and he had often
several hundred people working for him
as many times as a thousand and they
were dubbed the Nader's Raiders and is
incredible and they are done doing their
various muckraking Crusades they would
typically produce a report and these
reports were published and appeared in
bookstores sometimes where bestsellers
got a lot of attention they were
produced in this case often by people
were fresh out of college now one thing
that's very notable about the natives
Raiders is most of them for the for the
most part they were young white men and
the reason for this is very simple ralph
nader at this point was making lot of
speeches often at law schools which
provided his primary recruiting pool for
Nader's raiders and during this era most
of the people in law school were young
white men of course another issue that
came comes into play here is during this
era there were some other competing
areas that someone of an activist might
want to go into civil rights movement
the women's movement of course people
are interested in those issues
gravitated towards that away from Ralph
Nader who didn't
really delve into those areas another
thing that's notable about the young
white men the predominantly what young
white man who came to work for Ralph
Nader is often they were very there from
very wealthy families or they had family
money reason for this is simple to Ralph
Nader paid virtually nothing when he
could and when he could pay nothing at
all if he could get someone to volunteer
and so you have some natives Raiders
from that from that era but of course to
be able to go and work for Ralph Nader
spend time in Washington somebody had to
have if he was going to pay nothing or
if he's gonna pay a very small amount
someone often had to have some family
money so some natives Raiders from this
era include william howard taft the
fourth the great-grandson of the
president the one-time president and he
was certainly a purse of means another
Nader's raider from this era was Edward
Cox who is on his his for fought one of
his forefathers had been a signer of the
Declaration of Independence at a few
years later Edward Cox married and
Patricia and Nixon in a ceremony with a
lot of hoopla and I'm Ralph Nader
actually attended that ceremony so
basically you have during during this
period which you could describe sort of
his Nader's golden age from the
mid-1960s after the after the
publication of unsafe at any speed up
through the mid-1970s you have just a
period when he is ascended and it's a
sort of a glorious symbiosis he he had a
great command of the media Congress was
at his beck and call the mail was
pouring in and tons of young people want
to work with him and so I wanted to read
an excerpt from my book that kind of
when I did the research and learned
about this particular sort of lost
episode in Nader's history are in his
past it just struck me that this
particular episode reflected mater at
just the top of his powers and so I will
take a big go up of water and then I'll
read that
on November twentieth nineteen
sixty-nine Nader delivered speech at
Miss Porter's school in Farmington
Connecticut it was arranged by Robert
Townsend a former CEO of Avis rent-a-car
his daughter Claire Townsend was a
student there this Miss Porter's is an
exclusive girls finishing school founded
in 1843 and steeped in white glove
tradition among it's notable alumna
quaintly referred to as the ancients are
Jackie Onassis and Letitia Baldrige
denoted expert and etiquette as for
Robert Townsend he was a great admirer
of Nador like nadir Townsend was a
dedicated corporate or former those a
one-time CEO he approached the topic
from a vastly different perspective when
Townsend took over Avis in 1962 it had
not turned a profit in 13 years Townsend
level of hierarchies and freed up
communications among the employees his
management style was a timely mix of the
Industrial Age and the Aquarian age and
it succeeded in reinvigorating the
company town sins 1970 book up the
organization's a class of a classic of
contrarian management advice he'd also
serve as a major financial backer for
various native projects and years to
come Nader's miss Porter school
appearance was extremely successful the
school like Avis and just about every
other institution in America was going
through tremendous upheaval in 1969
among the 230 girls present for nader
speech for a number who had older
brothers serving in Vietnam many were
also starting to question the prescribed
roles they were expected to play in the
course of their lives debutante society
wife wealthy Dowager perhaps the wider
world was sneaking across the manicured
lawns at Miss Porter's school Lally
Lloyd was a student at the school in
1969 she attended Nader's speech and has
the following recollection he's a very
passionate speaker and he got us all
very stirred up we became excited about
the idea of what it was that we could
accomplish as consumers and his citizens
following the speech girls flocked
around Nader he was besieged by
questions the girls wanted to know what
they could do how they could fix what
ailed society they wanted to be Raiders
that night Claire Townsend filled her
diary with reactions to the big speech
interweaving impassioned notions about
how to make the world a better place
with assorted observations about NATO
himself first impression tall thin gaunt
second impression shy nervous third
impression funny and nice fourth
impression witty intelligent articulate
and concise
back in Washington Nader mulled over his
exuberant reception at Miss Porter's
school was there a project he wondered
that would be manageable and appropriate
for teenage girls how could he channel
all that youthful energy and idealism
then it hit him nursing homes teenagers
frequently worked as orderlies and the
subject matter abuse of the elderly with
far less demanding than much nadir fair
Nader selected five girls Claire
Townsend and Lally Lloyd among them to
spend the summer in DC conducting an
investigation of nursing homes Margaret
Quinn a 25 year old teacher at Miss
Porter's would accompany the girls as a
chaperone this was a strange new
subspecies of NATO Raider teenage and
female but also impossibly privileged
from the ladder standpoint they boring
market resemblance to the initial seven
[ __ ] tafton Taff for at all who had
investigated the FTC Claire Townsend
besides being the daughter of a
corporate chieftain lived an exclusive
Locust Valley long eyelid Lally Lloyd
was from a Tony Philadelphia suburb and
have been born into an investment
banking dynasty her father worked for
drexel burnham lambert the firm her
great-grandfather founded a big news
press dubbed the five the maiden
muckrakers an interview with the new
york times magazine nader explain the
logic in hiring a team of teenagers and
quotes the nursing home project did not
require the kind of specialized legal
and accounting knowledge that
investigating say first national city
bank does there's also a great deal of
suffering in nursing homes and the
industry is saturated with government
involvement I feel society is tested by
compassion by his treatment of the very
young and the very old so there was a
tremendous symbolic reason I wanted
young people on the project and why
young people such manifest privilege in
quotes there have been all kinds of
investigations in nursing homes and the
problems of the agent but they weren't
really dramatic with Claire and the
girls that would be the very young
reaching out to the very old and her
also were young pretty rich girls from
Jackie Onassis school and I felt that
these girls I felt that what these girls
did would be noticed off went the maiden
muckrakers chaperone tow to spend the
summer in Washington as a rule Nader
interns even those who had family money
tended to choose suitably CD
accommodations for the summer they might
crashing on a friend's couch or rental
vacant dorm room at one of the city's
many colleges not this group instead
Robert Townsend purchase a townhouse in
Southwest Washington so they could live
in the style to which they are a custom
the girls set up house divvied up
cooking nights and cleaning duties and
what a mongrel dog they named Ralph
first order of business was finding jobs
eights and orderlies the plan was for
the five is split up and work sub rosa
at various nursing homes they would keep
Diaries of the atrocities they observed
for use in a report here's a choice
excerpt from claire Townsend's diary the
nurse i was assigned to Ethel was so
kind to some patients is so mean to
others it was especially cruel when the
two extremes happened in the same room
with two patients well Ethel I were
putting the favorite patient the bed
doing a lot of extra fussing and smiling
taking a long time the other a patient
who was sitting on a chair in her own
filth kept saying girlie please put me
to bed but I know how to do it I've been
given no orientation and no training
whatsoever even though I said I'd never
done this type of work before so I just
stood there feeling helped us in
horrible waiting for Ethel finally Ethel
came over dragged the woman out of the
chair slammed her against a man and
began to undress her roughly the old
woman kept saying that she was slipping
in about the fall but Ethel just told
her to shut up an ethyl swung the old
woman into bed through the covers up
over the woman's face and left the room
besides nosing around nursing homes and
keeping Diaries nadir also won the girls
to do some original research he directed
them to interview various experts in
government in the elder care industry in
order to gain a deeper understanding of
the issues this aspect of the project
prove daunting Lally Lloyd interviewed a
specialist on for-profit nursing homes
at the Securities and Exchange
Commission in quotes this guy knew
perfectly well he could not resist an
interview request from ralph nader's who
recalls but he gave me nothing I only
got out of him what I knew enough to ask
for I don't think I was a as well
informed well prepared as I might have
been on another occasion the girls tried
to infiltrate a meeting of the American
nursing home Association just an
appropriate business attire the five
filed into the auditorium and took their
seats they thought they were being
discreet but they're also quite visibly
the only teenage girls present the next
speaker to the stage blew their cover I
understand we have some visitors here he
said well the young ladies who are
working for Ralph Nader please stand up
the girls arranged a strategy session
with Nader to learn how they might get
better results he gave them some tips on
how to play rough with sources one of
his suggestion was was to tell the
interviewee that someone from a
competing organization had promised the
same information and quotes I have a
source who can have the information
ready by next week but I thought maybe
you could give it to me now
as an alternate as an alternate approach
Nader suggests that the girls might try
to shake these nursing hombre arc rats
out of their complacency really remind
them of the true nature of their work
nader suggested saying something along
the lines of you seem to be caught up in
quite a bit of paperwork here do you
ever think about or even feel for the
1,000,000 nursing home patients around
the country the girls tried meters
hardball strategies but had limited
success what truly worked at least in
their case was inviting sources over to
the health townhouse for dinner they
discovered that a home-cooked meal
enjoying the company of calmly teenage
girls work wonders at loosening people
up dr. Robert Butler a Washington
psychiatrist who specialize in age of
patients stayed past midnight a font of
tips and leads and other useful pieces
of information the girls also tried to
get Nader to come over for dinner he was
rather hesitant impropriety the mirror
pre appearance of impropriety had been a
constant concern for him ever since the
alleged GM sex or incident in
intervening years his list of enemies
had only growing he had no doubt that
they were powerful interest out there
who would love to get some dirt dining
with teenage girls he felt had limited
potential to be twisted or misconstrued
Nader told the girls that maybe he would
accept their invitation if so he would
give them exactly 26 hours notice the
girls puzzled over this strange choice
why 26 hours one day late in the summer
nader called the girl's house Claire
Townsend answered it was 5pm nature said
he had decided to accept their dinner
offer expect him the next evening at
seven o'clock 26 hours the girls never
did figure out the reason for this quirk
as one time Raider Andrew negin Dorf
noted Nader like to conduct his life
like a spy as for playing the menu it
proved quite a challenge during their
phone conversation Claire ass inator if
he would like a chicken dish no oh she
pursued would he like any kind of meat
no are you a vegetarian no but just
about to become one I see what do you
like tomatoes onions and squash uh-huh
what do you like to drink you like wine
no milk no water no neither would you if
you knew what was in it what do you like
grapefruit juice the girls poured over a
Betty Crocker cookbook until they came
across a recipe calling for tomatoes
onions squash eggplant and green peppers
they also consulted with a Lebanese
friend who helped fix tabbouleh upon
sitting down to dinner Nader said grace
in Arabic a big hit by all accounts he
quite enjoyed his home cook Middle
Eastern meal prepared by five
Connecticut prep school girls he did not
stay past midnight at the close of the
summer the maid muckrakers participate
in a right already undertaken by a
number of other Nader teams they wrote a
report entitled old age the last
segregation that was 229 pages long the
bulk of it consisted of diary entries
were counting the grisly episodes the
team members of witness while working
undercover in various nursing homes
nader predicted the project would would
be dramatic and garden attention and it
did reviews were overwhelmingly
favorable there was some reservations
the consensus held that the passage from
the passages from the diaries were the
most effective part of the book they
provided a fresh I'd look at a human at
the human suffering existed in nursing
homes issue to which many suppose it
pundits had grown a nerd otherwise it
was agreed the book broke little new
ground the public policy recommendations
were unimaginative merely rehashing zuv
ideas in the existing literature then
again the authors are teenage girls the
five also got a chance to testify before
Congress they appear before the Senate
Subcommittee on long-term care Special
Committee on Aging chaired by Frank moss
of Utah before their testimony while
waiting around outside the Senate
committee room the girls started to get
a bit giggly Nader shush them above all
he cautioned you must be serious thank
you and they have a question
peers p ir g oh you just limit your book
to 85 is there a time limit no it's it's
a sure was it's now the book is a cradle
to present book and and the perks were
something that he started in the in
nineteen seventy i if i remember
correctly and there are public interest
research groups that's right and very
very strange maybe Nader's strange lyst
concept ever and also his most enduring
they still exist today many people might
know their i think they operate now in
26 States basically public interest
research group was the name of a law
firm he founded he decide the franchise
that kind of like Kentucky Fried Chicken
and his notion was that if he could set
up law firms near campuses near
university campuses that would work in
conjunction with the students on issues
that they were interested in like you
know fighting to keep from disrupting
the migratory pattern patterns of salmon
or fighting to keep a nuclear plant from
being built in the state that these law
firms could sort of combine the
professional ability of lawyers with the
idealism of students and so and the way
they would be financed is out of the
Student Activity fee if the campus voted
to have a perk then what would happen is
is out of the Student Activity fee which
also pays for the football team and
visiting guest lectures and so forth
they would finance a perk and he started
going around the country trying to
trying to sort of lobbying for this
concept in the late 60s and early 70s
and it was sort of a high-water mark
probably about the mid to late 70s when
there are a huge number of perks at a
huge number of campuses around the
country and today they're still if I
remember correctly 26 states that have
campuses that work with the perk so it's
it's bizarre concept that it was also
very I guess well thought out away and
it continues to this day
you I actually wonder what if you in the
research for your book if you came upon
anything about his orientation towards
the Vietnam War obviously that was the
height of his popularity sort of as you
described but it seems you know did he
ever use his his popularity to sort of
take a position towards the war or talk
about that much no absolutely not it was
a very conscious and careful decision on
his part as a great tactician he has
always avoided getting involved in
issues that are well served by other
people and there are a lot of those a
very vibrant fully formed anti-vietnam
movement and he resisted he was
constantly called upon to join this
movement to lend his good name to it as
it were and he refused and his reason
was he really wanted to concentrate on
what was narrow and also very broad
which was consumerism and he would
regularly make comments when he was
called upon to defend his conspicuous
absence from being a Vietnam protester
he would often respond that as many
people are killed on the highways in a
given year more people were killed in
the highways in a given year even there
in that era then had been killed in the
Vietnam War so far so he was
concentrating on a place he that he
would say what great carnage was taking
place so now he's been he was always
very willful and very careful candy and
avoiding becoming involved in things
like civil rights the vietnam war etc
yes i just want to ask you a question
about the actual writing of the book
fact that he's a very private
sort of well-publicized and so how did
you go about actually you know getting
permission to ride the book and get the
interviews with him and so forth and how
was that the interview is very well I i
did a sort of a classic biographers
technique which was i started
researching the book without permission
and and I I simply you know I got I got
permission from my publisher which which
meant that I you know had sent some
reason to go out and start with this
undertaking and I you know I sent a
request to him early in the going and it
took a while from the respond in the
meantime I just started interviewing
tons and tons of people would work with
them over the years one thing to that
sort of notable about Ralph Nader is he
has worked he's rubbed shoulders with
and worked with thousands and thousands
of people he's off he's also parted ways
poorly with the vast majority of them
it's incredible he really clashes with a
lot of his former employees and by
virtue of that there was a huge pool of
people out there who were comfortable
talking about him and quite willing to
talk about him the two thousand election
furthermore alienated a lot of his I
mean many former NATO rights many former
Nader Raiders are Democrats some of them
are Republicans any of those folks were
happy to talk people I felt you know
many people kind of got their start with
him he sort of shaped their view of
advocacy that they're carrying through
this day so people weren't necessarily
negative about him but they were
comfortable talking about the good and
the bad because you know he people sort
of passed through his organization as
not not too many people have stuck with
him over the many years so there's a
huge number of people out there who have
Nader experiences it were so I started
by talking to a lot of them and then
gradually you know when it became clear
to him I guess that I was you know doing
a serious um you know that I wasn't
trying to do a hatchet job or anything
like that he was comfortable and was
willing to talk with me and you had a
question well you described us there's
great legacy that he has of the 60s and
even into the 70s wit deez maybe you
wrote this in the book I don't know but
what do you think will be hit the legacy
of his experience with the Green Party
good question his first and foremost he
may not even I mean it would not
surprise me if he ran for president
again it would not surprise me if you
ran for president not as a member of the
Green Party one thing that's interesting
is he never joined the Green Party even
though he's their presidential candidate
he say he likes to hold himself
vigorously and appended he's never been
a Democrat certainly never been a
Republican he's never been a green
either so and the green it was kind of a
marriage of convenience between NATO and
the Greens the Greens needed someone who
had a national stature and if you look
at the recent election you'll see that a
lot of the people that the Greens field
is candidates there their names are
fairly anonymous and so Nader's really
there one you know their superstar
basically so they needed him in order to
have you know a viable candidate with
great name recognition he needed them to
make use of their party machinery and
the people they had on the ground and
they actually didn't really see to eye
to eye on a huge number of issues i'll
give you one funny one that happened at
the at the nominating convention nader
and his crew at the nominating
convention believed that there should be
green balloons and their point was
balloons are presidential the Green
Party felt that balloons that birds
might choke on them and so they had this
big clash back and forth and ultimately
Nader one and he was able to have green
balloons but throughout the election the
there's a lot of internal I mean the
greens are very fractious group that
begin with in any case and throughout
the election there was a real I mean
Nader basically hijacked their their
their party in order to run for
president but his big issue is is the
way that corporations pervert the
democratic process which it's kind of
like a Venn diagram it has some
correspondence with the Green Party's
issues but the Green Party has also into
a lot of issues such as obviously the
environment and so forth which Nader
mater is not that great of an
environmental environmentalist and when
he is interested in environment usually
has to do with how corporations you know
he's not someone who goes out and loves
and appreciates nature so basically the
Greens the nadir marriage of convenience
is the best way to describe it and as
for his for their legacy I'm not sure
that they'll they'll be too associated
for too much longer
one of those people I think you alluded
to I really admired him and loved this
politics I I'll bring them to my law
school 20 years ago I was had a DC /
call that stuff mm-hmm and I'm really
furious Adam for what he did in two
thousand I am furious at him and I think
the elections the other night come out
of the fact that he gave the election to
bush and I just don't I had a lunch day
with a guy who used to work for him and
we always think about the issue of how
he supposedly treated his workers that
was another thing that always bothered
you might want to touch on that but I
mean I just thought that his politics
were so great he did so many great
things and I think he's going to be
remembered for in large part for the two
thousand election I I understand his
reasoning he wanted to build a more
progressive movement etc etc but for
such a brilliant guy to say there's no
difference between I guess what we we
would have had under gore and under Bush
maybe some people would disagree I I
just don't understand it court wouldn't
even need a floridi would have wanted in
New Hampshire if Nader had it so and we
saw months later and he's still
unrepentant he tells the New York Times
he's unrepentant no difference well
there's plenty of difference with the
Supreme Court and with warranty rock etc
and what was he thinking why did he do
it yeah I guess I'll take the last piece
of what was he thinking why did he do it
you know he was somebody who the period
that I described in the little sort of
speech i did there from the late 60
through the early 70s me he was like a
shadow congressional whip basically I
mean he was he was more effective than
most members of Congress and he was he
was very effective working within the
political process then you have you know
through the 80s with with with Reagan as
president later with Bush one as
president you have made a really fading
from view not really able to get those
audiences with Congress anymore he
starts trying to figure different things
he can do it the grassroots working with
the pervs in some cases and so forth and
ultimately he concludes that he is going
to run for president and so I guess
that's the why he did it as for whether
it was a good thing whether it'll be a
blight on his record I guess the answer
to that is he's he's one of the my
answer to that would be he's one of the
youngest sixty eight year olds you'll
ever encounter
his heroes a guy named Norman Thomas who
ran for president six times as a
socialist final time Norman Thomas ran
he got 10,000 votes but he kept at it
and I think that you know I know this
the classic eff scott Fitzgerald comment
that you know there are no second acts
in American life Nader's is young enough
yet and energetic enough I wouldn't be
surprised if you had a third or even
fourth act that's just that's my own
candid opinion it says Crusader I was
gonna say if you would go into remember
what you this boiler or I know yet
pastor do you have more could you in a
perennial bit more on this spoiler and
also does he have any sense of humor oh
that's like her I'll take the first
question first cuz i love that I did I
love that question the firt the the I've
done two biographies now the first one
was was Alan Greenspan and the second
one was Ralph Nader one thing I can tell
you about anybody you do particularly
serious people if you're if they're your
biography subjects the little secret
thing that people try to tell you about
them the sort of thing you might not
know is that they're secretly a really
funny guy well I can tell you alan
greenspan is not a funny guy and Ralph
Nader is not a funny guy yeah so and
people point to you know I mean he's had
a whole lifetime he's occasionally said
so he's clever and he's angry and clever
but he certainly lacks the empathy to be
a you know stand-up comedian or anything
so so that's the that's the first part
of the question of the more serious part
yes the spoiler well let's see I guess
later has has given all kinds of
contradictory answers to whether he was
a spoiler and I guess I would have to
say myself my own personal view which is
not probably well that important is that
you know anybody should be able to run
for president and I guess to quote Ralph
Nader he said Al Gore slipped on some
time 15 banana peels I was one of them
and I personally by that I feel like you
know I feel like if Gord run a better
campaign Nader would have been not in
fact maybe even a derby someone people
were pleased he was there you know sort
of pushing Gore back to the back to the
left more um but knit but to speak to
sort of the deeper point of him being a
spoiler he's certainly unrepentant as
people have pointed out he's gleeful you
a gleeful hatred for the Democrats a
gleeful hatred for Gore he's also set a
huge number of very contradictory things
one of the most one thing he certainly
made mention of periodically I saw him
at a Green Party function where he
talked about he didn't describe it so
many terms but it's sort of this notion
that if you push things if you push the
pendulum far to the right and they'll
swing back wonderful flee to the left
which is kind of a silly way to look at
history because it means make things bad
so they'll become good again and so he
kind of takes credit for you know when
things go bad he actually you know and
he actually calls up I interviewed an
old friend of his from from Princeton
who he calls up periodically Keth can
you believe this john ashcroft you know
and and he's sort of without any irony
or since it well maybe I had some role
in there being this john ashcroft so so
I guess one thing is certainly the case
is anybody has a right to run for
president in in my view at least and you
can certainly look in fact and see that
Harry Brown the Libertarian candidate he
took more than five hundred thirty five
votes from bush in Florida so
technically Harry Brown is a spoiler as
well but what distinguishes harry brown
from nader his Harry Brown was just out
there you know libertarian talking about
driving fast and smoking pot and those
were his issues and he heated to that
whereas Nader Nader was very gleeful
about wanting to attack Gore he aimed a
lot more firepower and gore than he did
at bush and he's been unrepentant in the
aftermath and made many contradictory
comments including the ones at which he
thrills at thrills at the contradiction
the fact that the republicans are in in
power so maybe the pendulum swing back
the other way so the net of that is his
spoiler is certainly part of his legacy
that's a good question it actually isn't
is actually referring to an interesting
period it mean it's obviously referring
to the 2000 election but but i wanted to
sort of identify the origins of his
playing spoiler and strangely enough
when Jimmy Carter became president you
would think that would be Nader's golden
moment and instead it was the beginning
of the end for him as a figure as
powerful as he was in the 60s because
what happened was the government was
flooded I mean jimmy carter met with
Nader several times before after being
elected president before becoming
president during the transition period
and he met with him and was really
showed a great
obviously essence I mean he said you
know what should I do who can I bring
into the government and Carter actually
listened inator and brought a huge
number of Nador associates and former
Nader Raiders into the government and
what did Nader do he attacked his former
colleagues and said you know why can't
you get this done why can't you do this
fast enough and so people who should
have been his allies in government
instead he completely alienated them and
the Carter Administration most people
date the beginning of his declined to
the Reagan era but it actually the
Carter Administration Nader was so
churlish and so difficult with his
former colleagues in government that
nothing got done and he'd be at that
point he sort of played spoiler to his
own movement as it were mmm-hmm I think
it's a good app description yes I think
it's interesting of course we're
especially worse Amy didn't wasn't able
to get support from people supporting
them civil rights movement or the
women's movement you said
and care much about the environment I
mean I think the reason he can be
gleeful is that he doesn't care very
much about things that are very very
important to a lot of people in this
country and it's all well and good for
him to be gleeful and an act as spoiler
but these issues ever as an enormous
relevance to so many people in this
country I think he bears a great weight
of responsibility and I think you should
be ashamed we know you're dead on what
you say mean there's certainly something
about Nader which is he's he's he's
distant hiromu he's removed he likes to
have a sort of it's a theoretical
criticism of how corporations are
perverting democracy but then when it
gets down to actual people and their
daily lives he has a bad track record on
the opinions he's expressed when he ran
when he ran for the green tea actually
this is a second time around 2000 as
right as the green party candidate he
actually ran in 1996 and one of the
green party platforms at that point was
a gay marriage platform and William
Safire interviewed him about this and
Ralph Nader's response was I'm not
interested in go Natalie tix and that as
you might imagine really stuck in the
craw off a lot of gay people in fact in
two thousand when he ran again a lot of
gay people who were greens actually
broke away annoyed remembering the go
nan-oh politics comment during the 2002
him that if in fact bush was elected
that it was possible that Bush would
nominate certain justices who might
start the ich away at or even ultimately
overturn Roe versus Wade and Nader's
response on a I can't remember the talk
show but on a national talk show was
well if ro versus Wade is overturned it
goes back it reverts to the states which
is from a legal from a pure legal
standpoint absolutely true that's right
if it was overturned you know the state
of New York could continue to to have
abortions be legal the state of Alabama
could make them illegal but to make a
comment like that that if Roe vs. Wade
were overturned it would revert to the
states showed a real legalistic mind at
work and it didn't think about the fact
well that would be of immense anxiety to
a lot of people and in certain states
where it would be quickly overturned or
the overturning of it would be upheld
bad news so now
wealthy white man's booth you know those
those were his his Raiders he has a
classic criticism of the Nader's Raiders
and in it's a classic criticism as as
many people might know if the Green
Party interestingly enough as well so
yeah mhm oh go ahead I'm sorry I just
let the speak to that point cuz I think
it's an interesting one I mean is the
conception that all wealthy white men
should be Republicans then I mean I'm
not sure I mean as you know a
professional white man I take exception
to the comment that you know again
somehow wealthy are looking at well off
white people shouldn't be working on the
half of the rights of workers of the
environment so I just think the you know
that comment I'm not exactly sure what
the proper response yeah that's a fit I
mean that's a certainly it was it was
good that he had people working for him
in there and they were doing good they
were there helping and some of them
later became Republican it's actually a
surprising number of them did so it
wasn't as if you know these were future
Republicans doing doing good things on
these various issues but I guess it is
also notable that he's he's certainly
you know there's an elitist element to
him which is notable you know he went to
Princeton went on to Harvard and he's
always been interested at me to give an
example he's never been interested in
getting involved in the messy stuff
civil rights gay rights what have you
he's always preferred to have clean-cut
young often white man rifling through
the files of an obscure government
agency trying to find out about what
corruption is involved which is a worthy
pursuit and much more worthy than other
things that other people are doing of
all races and creeds but it is notable
that he's never wanted to get his hands
messy and some of these other issues
if as you indicate that he's currently
still that concerned about corporate
ethics I think what we've seen the past
several months within one world calm and
so on these would be tailor-made issues
for him why has he been appears to me
conspicuously silent current lack of
credibility because of the two thousand
election which I you know largely agree
with this gentleman over there that he
had inflicted enormous damage on this on
this country simply by causing bush
great great question might just say
parenthetically that I've heard through
a number of interviews his stock phrase
is you know will help you do this with
so much at stake in the country in the
world you know you cost Al Gore that one
percent that would have made the
difference in this large state and so on
and his response very sarcastically has
always been no it's actually the outdoor
cost me 40 acres yep that's he likes he
likes to say that that's a favorite a
chestnut for him I'll speak to your
question which is a very good one which
is why would I mean what what a
tailor-made as you said worldcom tyco
Enron Martha Stewart the list goes on
and on why is he so conspicuously absent
I actually talked to him about that one
of the last interviews I had with him he
said he just can't one is he just can't
get any traction for one thing if he was
to become involved in these issues one
thing he would necessarily need to do is
work with Congress he can't work with
Congress anymore he he lost that
constituency a long long time ago
another interesting things worth noting
is because he set in motion an entire
movement that that seeks to look at acts
of corporate malfeasance and crime and
so forth there are other people have
sort of picked up the mantle for him and
so there are other organizations out
there that kind of maybe Nader set in
motion which are on the case the final
thing is definitely as you say I'm
there's a credibility gap that hurts him
that makes it difficult for him to get
involved in this he's um he's been
trying to put together a what he calls a
Citizens Coalition on Enron to get real
substantive stuff done as he terms at
versus the sort of the window dressing
that Congress has been
undertaking but you know it hasn't
hasn't made much of our ripple at this
point bodies are exactly the same does
does he believe that yes why do you know
all the corporate malfeasance that's
transpired in several months he still he
still fix it on man now you see still
believes that there you know very close
together so yes so painted a picture of
a man was very interested in narrow
issue he corporate malfeasance consumer
advocacy right she is defaulting Vietnam
and the vehicle demonstration civil
rights small as all of sudden the
propulsion was the imposed it it's like
okay so he specialized was something
what was the impulse that had him seek
this sort of a national office 22
brought away in fact you do have to care
about a much broader spectrum of issues
what was good question when he expanded
his critique his critique has always
been the corporations he originally
viewed is as the producers versus the
consumers and he felt that the balance
was tilted in America producers had too
much power and consumers had too little
power he was trying to seek to redress
the balance he would say that he simply
broaden his critique to include the fact
that corporations not only were hurting
consumers of goods and services but
hurting the consumers of our democracy
and basically it was just a broad me or
expanding of his this is how he would
justify his choice to run for president
that things like campaign finance reform
a huge issue of course the corporations
were buying buying members of Congress
basically and so and so they were
perverting democracy that the same
corporations that once upon a time the
biggest danger they pose was faulty cars
such as the Chevrolet Corvair that they
are now actually posting as a threat to
democracy and that would be his argument
that was his justification for for
running of course the fascinating thing
was once he ran that was his focus issue
and all the other issues that come with
me a national leader issues like Roe
versus Wade gay rights you name it he
had yet he was very toned ethanol the
host and so he wasn't very well
positioned to to take up the huge ball
of wax that most presidential candidates
have to consider and be able to speak to
I actually have only two more questions
so I should see if anybody else has a
fresh one I'm taking rigid intolerant
judgmental three adjectives you would
use to describe well I picked one of
those and I probably say may be
judgmental but I'd also said relentless
and I'd also say it's not necessarily an
adjective i'd say brilliant tactician
he's a mean he he was a big chess player
back in high school and he's often
described his work as playing 50 games
of chess simultaneously and I actually
believed that in his mind it's probably
kind of what he's doing he's a
incredible tactician and although he is
the things you mentioned and also I
believe relentless there's a good reason
why you know here 40 years since he
first came the national problem is I
mean you can't find a rock star who
lasted that long you can't find a movie
star who's been around that long you can
find strom thurmond but otherwise you
got Ralph Nader so it's it's a some of
that tactician that ability as a
tactician which has allowed him to go
from being as I described them earlier a
shadow congressional whip to being a
great grassroots organizer to being a at
least I interesting to being a spoiler
yes so one last question anyway why
would you say that ralph was so
successful in taking on Corvair and
General Motors how does a guy that
didn't have a whole lot of power much
connection why was he so successful it
seems to me that the newspapers could
have ignored him put it off what's the
car that bad you may have just touched
on the bisectors of your breeding
soldier
tactician but what if you could come in
you know the main thing was was he was
the benefit of just a great circumstance
and that was I mean people weren't you
know the topic of the faulty engineering
of the Corvair which was detailed in
what appeared in great detail in unsafe
at any speed before the spy scandal that
happened in the aftermath of that
because General Motors is a very
interesting thing that's kind of the
collision of two paranoid forces general
motors was so paranoid that this book
that actually had they not done anything
would have just it wouldn't made much of
a you know wouldn't make much of a
ripple down the line probably these
innovations were to happen seat belts
and so forth various people would have
gotten credit for them maybe Nate or
even would have played a role but he
wouldn't been launched instantly on the
national stage had not been for General
Motors paranoia about the fact that
they've been mentioned adversely in this
book and the fact that they hired spies
to tail him around that create this big
spy scandal and then on the flip side of
it I'm fascinating thing is nadir
himself it's always been a very paranoid
person kind of kept his goings doings
and goings very secret and so that was
part of the reason than the spies were
tailing Nader they were very puzzled by
a lot of his strange behavior the fact
that he lived in a rooming house in
downtown Washington an unlisted number
where they call and somebody pick up the
phone mr. as people pick up the phone
and say phones4u Ralph and he he works
at night and sleeps during today during
this year and all these things and so he
got this get paranoid General Motors
clashing or coming together with
paranoid Ralph Nader and wondering why
this guy's so sneaky and it just creates
this this incredible event that
basically it was a very carrot it was a
very charismatic or very compelling
event that General Motors which at that
time was the biggest corporation in the
world that their CEO was called for
Congress to apologize to a you know a
private citizen who at that point people
didn't know much about him except all
he's a diligent serious young man and
General Motors put spies on his tail so
that was a easy thing for the press
which which obviously needs you know
kind of sound bites to build a grasp on
to you know David versus Goliath Ralph
Nader versus General Motors and that
launched him into national acclaim
instantly so well think big times up
here but I thank everybody for coming
out it was a pleasure
Justin Martin is author of Nador
Crusader spoiler icon it's published by
Perseus visit Perseus Books com from